[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wird ich habe heute wieder eine
richtig schöne motiv torte für euch und
zwar gibt es eine torte zum ersten
geburtstag meiner großcousine der erste
geburtstag wird bei uns immer ganz groß
gefeiert denn ein baby hat er auch nur
einmal den ersten geburtstag und es ist
einfach ein ganz besonderer anlass
deswegen gibt es heute eine dreistöckige
geburtstagstorte im stil einer
prinzessin oder einer königin sozusagen
mit einer richtig schönen krone
ich habe jetzt einfach vom rezept her
mein rezept von der hochzeitstorte
genommen die ich schon mal gemacht hab
das rezept verlinkt ich euch einfach in
die infobox heute soll es einfach nur um
die gestaltung der torte gehen damit das
video jetzt auch nicht so lange wird und
ich habe jetzt bevor ich gestartet habe
mit der torte eine woche vorher schon
die krone hergestellt es gibt aber ein
extra video denn die krone muss einfach
vorher ausgedruckt wird sein und einfach
schon mal fertig sein und eine anleitung
wie man die torte richtig befüllt und
bestreicht worauf man sie setzen kann
und wie man schlussendlich die torte
stapelt habe ich bereits auch in meinem
hochzeitstorten video mit dabei da gibt
es die anleitung einfach schritt für
schritt die krone und die ziffer 1 habe
ich bereits eine woche fordert heute
hergestellt und ich werde euch einfach
in einem extra video zeigen wie man
diese zwei dekoelemente herstellt am
ersten tag habe ich meine drei wiener
böden gebacken und zwar haben die einen
durchmesser von 16 22 und 28 zentimetern
und diese habe ich dann über nacht
einfach abgedeckt und stehen lassen um
sie dann am nächsten tag zu befüllen
am zweiten tag habe ich meine erste
programm und meiner kanal schräg
gestellt und habe dann die torte in
einzelne böden aufgeteilt und die torten
einzeln befüllt zusätzlich zur
buttercreme habe ich auch etwas etwa
marmelade benutzt damit die torte etwas
fruchtige frische schlägt wenn daran
tatorte mal nicht so schön glatt ist ist
es gar kein problem ich stürze dann
meine torten in der regel auf eine torte
unterlage und schneidet an den rand
richtig schön glatt ab dazu dient mir
dann einfach die körper platter als
hilfe die ja einen schönen runden
durchmesser hat und so kann ich die
torte exakt zurechtschneiden dem rest
erledigt dann die gage die wir dann
später auf die torte streichen und sie
dann erkalten lassen
[Musik]
wenn die torte seien komplett glatt
gestrichen ist gebe ich sie wieder in
den kühlschrank und lasse etwas abkühlen
und werde dann in der zwischenzeit meine
von land herausnehmen um innen weich zu
kneten
ich habe jetzt hier wieder meinen weißen
deko macht vom band das ist jetzt ein
kilo eimer das auch ganz praktisch weil
ich daten von dann einfach wieder drin
verstauen und verschließen kann und zum
verkneten nehme ich mir einfach jetzt
etwas palmen soft und kneteten fondant
war
[Musik]
dieses ein kilo fondant habe ich jetzt
benutzt um eine mittlere torte damit zu
überziehen und muss jetzt den von hand
natürlich vorher aus dem ausrollen
das funktioniert am besten wenn ihr dazu
etwas becker sterkel benutzt und dann
gefunden immer wieder mit kreisenden
bewegungen mit einem großen silikon aus
buchstaben ausbauen um die torte dann
damit einzudecken wolle ich die fondant
decke auch meinen ausrutscher auf und
lege sie dann ganz vorsichtig über meine
traute trüber vorhabe spricht die torte
noch mit etwas back translate damit der
vom land einfach auf der kann etwas
haften kann jetzt arbeite ich von oben
nach unten mit einem gitter und die
hatte zuerst einmal die oberfläche und
nehme dann grob die überreste des fonds
mit einem marzipan messer weg und kehrte
dann die ränder von oben nach unten mit
den händen glatt
zum abschluss nämlich immer mal
dort hat unterstreicht damit den rand
glatt und so ist jetzt meine mittlere
torte eingedeckt und ich kann sie in den
kühlschrank stellen und in der zeit
bereits die anderen 2 1 deckung für die
22 zentimeter torte habe ich jetzt
insgesamt etwa 300 gramm 100 gebraucht
ihr seht ich habe jetzt noch knapp 700
gramm übrig von dem kino
das kann ich jetzt gleich weiter
verwenden für die kleine und die große
etage weiter ging es bei mir mit der
kleinen etage mit 16 cm durchmesser
dafür habe ich mir jetzt den
rosafarbenen deko back von hand genommen
und habe dafür zwei päckchen also 500
gramm verwendet und diese ebenfalls mit
palmen etwas bekundet
dieser form dann hier dann auch dünn
ausgerollt auf becker starken und über
die kleine zarte gelebt
[Musik]
und die wird ebenfalls schön glatt
gestrichen und dann in den kühlschrank
gegeben
[Musik]
von den ursprünglich 500 gramm hatte ich
jetzt noch etwa 320 gramm übrig ich habe
also für die kleine torte mit 16 cm
durchmesser etwa 150 gramm vom land
benötigt und werde jetzt den rest an
rosa und weiß vermischen um damit die
größte torte einzudecken
[Musik]
das sind dann insgesamt wieder etwa ein
kino und dieses kino reicht dann für
meine torte mit dem durchmesser von 28
zentimetern aus
[Musik]
und auch diese torte wird dann schön
glatt gestrichen und kommt dann in den
kühlschrank
die mittlere etage habe ich jetzt mit
streifen dekoriert und habe dafür
rosafarbenen und weißen fondant benutzt
und diesen mit hilfe meiner
nudelmaschine ganz dünn ausgerollt auf
etwa einen halben millimeter dem von
dort habe ich dann in 2 cm breite
streifen geschnitten das geht ganz gut
mit hilfe eines dreiecks und eines regen
jahren und habe dann mit hilfe der wachs
papiertechnik die deko elemente an die
torte gebracht dafür nehmt ihr euch
einfach ein stück wachs papier und
streicht es mit etwas palm ihn ein
dann kommen da die weißen und
rosafarbenen streifen im wechsel drauf
und durch das palm ihn haften sie
einfach an diesem wachstum und ich achte
da immer drauf und hälfte einfach mit
einem lineal immer nach dass die
streifen immer schön gerade drauf liegen
und arbeitet da nicht komplett die torte
in einem zug durch sondern benutzt das
backpapier etwa 3 km h um die torte in
drei bis vier schritten einzudecken
die streifen werden dann oben und unten
in der höhe der torte einfach
abgeschnitten damit sie oben und unten
einen guten abschluss haben und dann
wird die oberfläche mit etwas kleber
eingestrichen und zur kamera dann das
wachstum hier anheben und an die torte
setzen
[Musik]
der rest wird dann wieder mit den
fingern und mit dem sofa glatt
gestrichen und dann kann man das wachs
papier abziehen und auch die details
ausarbeiten
[Musik]
auf die mittlere torte wollte ich dann
noch den namen des babys schreiben und
habe deswegen etwas blüten passte ganz
dünn ausgerollt und mehr eine schablone
aus papier hergestellt und mit einem
cutter einfach entlang ausgeschnitten
mit meinen buchstaben ausstellern habe
ich dann den namen ist es so eingeprägt
und habe eine spritztour benutzt um noch
ein paar feinheiten reinzubringen
mit hilfe von etwas zucker kleber habe
ich dann das namensschild auch meine
torte mit dies angeklebt und hab dann
etwas goldfarbene pulver farbe mit ein
bisschen alkohol vermischt und damit den
namen zu bestreichen
[Musik]
damit das ganze so etwas zu lehrer habe
ich jetzt noch mit hilfe von etwas vom
land eine bordüre gemacht und die auch
mit hilfe von wachs papier angebracht
ich habe jetzt dafür ein paar bordüre
aus stanz und habe mir einfach einen
langen streifen auf sondern
zurechtgeschnitten und diesen dann auch
wenn wachsen ob ihr aufgebracht und
anschließend konnte ich dann mit diesem
baut ihren standort die bordüre aus
stampfen danach mit dem lineal den rand
oben abschneiden und zum anbringen auf
die torte damit sich einfach nichts
verschiebt habe ich einfach eine kleine
ferien genommen und die bordüre darauf
aufgewickelt und die torte mit kleber
eingestrichen und die bordüre entlang
wieder ausgebaut
[Musik]
für die kleinste etage war die
dekoration ziemlich einfach denn ich
habe dafür einfach ein paar zuckerperlen
in pink und rosa benutzt und diese auf
einem teller vermischt ich habe jetzt
etwa von jeder sorte also von rosa und
pink circa 70 gramm gebraucht also
insgesamt ungefähr 140 bis 170 gramm und
habe dann meine torte komplett ganz dünn
mit etwas zucker kleber eingepinselt und
jetzt geht es ganz einfach ihr müsst
jetzt nur noch die torte über eine große
schüssel halten und die perlen einfach
drüber fallen lassen
durch den zucker kleber kleben sie dann
an und mit den händen kann man die
zuckerperlen etwas streichen und den
überrest einfach wieder in die schüssel
zurückgeben und die perlen später für
etwas anders benutzen
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt die unterste etage noch
dekoriere denke ich erst mal meinen
cache bord ein und zwar habe ich es hier
eine pinkfarbene skateboard und decke
dieses mit weißer blüten passten die
habe ich einfach auch bäcker starke ganz
dumm aus gewohnt habe dann das
skateboard mit etwas zucker kleber
gestrichen und die blüten passt
innendecke einfach drauf gelegt zum
gatten könnt ihr einfach mal mit einem
aus und starb drüber rollen und später
mit einem smoother alles schön klippen
die reste werden dann mit einem marzipan
messer wieder abgeschnitten
und weil mir das so dann zu langweilig
und zu glatt war habe ich dann wieder
die bordüre genommen und haben uns herum
mit der pop göre einfach das muster
eingestanzt
[Musik]
die letzten details habe ich dann mit
meinem ornamente stammte eingestampft
und habe so die komplette platte erst
einmal trocknen lassen
das ging dann relativ schnell weil es
beim sehr aus mythen passte besteht und
nach etwa einer halben stunde
trocknungszeit könnte ich die blüten
passen platte jetzt mit dem gold
bestreiten
das habe ich dann natürlich wieder mit
etwas alkohol angemischt und dieses
trocknet dann auch sehr schnell und
zurück bleibt dann einfach nur dieser
verfahren das board müsst ihr dann nicht
komplett einstreichen das war ja eine
verschwendung denn in der mitte steht ja
später die torte drauf und dort wo man
das skateboard nicht sieht für mich die
tortenplatte auch nicht bestücken die
platte habe ich dann zum trocknen wieder
weg gestellt und konnte jetzt meine
unterste etage dekorieren für die
unterste etage werde ich jetzt ein paar
büscheln vorbereiten und dafür brauche
ich wieder rosafarbenen fondant ich
brauche weiße blüten passte und ich
brauche die passende farbe rot und rosa
die sind ebenfalls und depotbank an
werkzeug brauche ich eine blume modell
ihr platte und ein paar teams und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier einen whirlpool und
einen
um die röhrchen zu modellieren vermisse
ich jetzt einen teil von dann mit einem
teil blüten passte das heißt ich erhalte
jetzt modelliermasse dieses teile ich
jetzt in drei gleich große portionen um
einen effekt zu erzielen
eine teil der farbe belasse ich so den
anderen teil vermische ich mich etwas
weißer blüten passte den anderen mit
rosafarbenem von land und den dunkelsten
teil werde ich jetzt mit rosa und rot
wieder einfärben damit dieses eben die
dunkelste und unterste farbe annimmt so
sehen dann meine farbabstufungen aus und
diese werde ich jetzt einen haken damit
sie nicht austrocknen
ich beginne jetzt mit der hälfte farbe
rolle mir die modelliermasse mit meiner
nudelmaschine wieder ganz schön aus und
schneidet dieses lange stück bei den
etwa 15 breite streifen die ich dann
etwa auf 15 cm länge zuschneiden
die einzelnen stücke muss ich jetzt mit
dem board tool auf einer seite ausdünnen
und das geht am besten wenn ich da auf
diesem blumen modelliert arbeitet denn
das ist weich und ihr braucht einfach
eine weiche unterlage um jetzt den rand
etwas auszudünnen
jetzt wird bei der torte oben begonnen
und zwar wird jetzt oben der rand mit
superkleber eingestrichen und jetzt lege
ich mir dieses lange stück
modelliermasse in feine prüfen und klebt
sie am rand entlang
das ganze darf sehr unregelmäßig sein es
soll kein muster entstehen sondern es
soll wirklich schöne weiche büschen
entstehen
und so habe ich jetzt von jeder farbe
etwa drei reihen gemacht das ganze darf
auch hier unregelmäßig starten
denn so erhalten wir später eine
schönere schönefeld
ihr müsst jetzt darauf achten dass man
den untergrund also die torte nicht
sieht und die röschen setzt sich immer
so etwa mit 5 mm abstand nach unten an
um dann eben von oben nach unten zu
arbeiten
[Musik]
und den letzten abschluss werden wir
erst dran setzen wenn die torte auf dem
keyboard sitzt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die torte mit etwas
realizing also mit einer spritztour auf
die tortenplatte geklebt unter der torte
steckt ja eine kupferplatte und deswegen
gibt mir das so den richtigen haltung
und die torte verrutscht nicht auf dem
untergrund
jetzt habe ich den torten rand mit
einbrüchen abschließen und damit ihr
einfach darauf achten dass beide seiten
von dem band eben aus gewöhnt werden
denn so erhaltet ihr die perfekte optik
die taten werden jetzt mit hilfe von
rundhölzern oder zb mit cake pops ticks
gestapelt und immer zwischen rein kommt
eine kleine schicht wild thing damit die
torten zusammenhalten und später beim
transport nicht auseinander rutschen
den genauen ablauf des stapels könnt ihr
auch in meinem hochzeit zutaten videos
sehen die oberste etage bekommt jetzt
bei mir noch einen abschluss einen rand
aus von land und diesen werde ich dann
auch mit der goldfarbe einpinseln
[Musik]
so sieht meine fertige torte jetzt aus
und jetzt kann ich auch die krone und
die ziffer darauf platzieren und traten
fertig dekorieren ich werde sie
allerdings gleich zum transport wieder
abnehmen
[Musik]
ich hab jetzt im endeffekt für die torte
insgesamt etwa vier tage gearbeitet
jeweils so etwas sechs bis sieben
stunden - natürlich die krone also
soviel zeit müsst ihr euch einfach
einrechnen und müsst ihr euch natürlich
auch reservieren denn ich finde wenn man
so eine torte macht sollte man sich auf
jeden fall mit viel geduld machen und
einfach auf die details achten wenn die
details machen die torte erst richtig
schön
die fertige torte könnt ihr dann einfach
über nacht im kühlschrank lagern
ich habe sie erst am tag des platzes
zusammen gesetzt denn mein kühlschrank
ist zwar groß genug
aber ich wollte einfach an dem tag
fertigstellen und dann eben mit auf die
reise nehmen
ich habe die torte übrigens über 100
kilometer transportiert habe sie einfach
in eine große kiste gegeben und rechts
und links so ein paar styropor kisten
gestellt oder so ein paar styropor
polster gestellt damit sie einfach nicht
verrutscht und das hat auch super
funktioniert und die krone habe ich
einfach einzeln auf einem styropor stück
transportiert und mit zahnstochern
darauf fixiert die fertige torte hat
natürlich perfekt zum saal und zu der
dekoration dort gefasst meine cousine
hat sich da richtig viel mühe gegeben
und ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz
[Musik]
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
und ihr könnt einfach so ein paar
hilfreiche tipps mitnehmen für eure
nächste motiv torte ich finde mich auf
jeden fall freuen wenn es euch geholfen
hat freue mich über eure kommentare und
wir sehen uns dann einfach wieder beim
nächsten mal bis bald murat des gehwegs
sollen hintergrund ich kann später
putzen
mein gott so schön dass du pont während
ich wäre fast der ganze tag gekauft
[Musik]